i think that when um you know you
know yourself well and you you've lived
a life with lots of ups and downs and
you get to be in your four days i think
you feel pretty good all the time
gwyneth paltrow is celebrating her
birthday in the buff
and her 16 year old daughter yeah she's
not here for it
you want to see a splash i'm going to
show you a splash ready the shallow
house star
definitely made a splash on her 48th
birthday
by posting a fully nude photo to her
instagram
yep there's gwyneth posing in nature
smiling ear to ear
rocking nothing but her birthday suit
it's a good combination
sexiness intelligence you know that's
that's sort of the goal i think
naturally the actress got lots of love
from celeb pals like courtney cox
vanessa hudgins and katy perry
but her daughter apple that's a
different story
apple oh my god the 16 year old left a
comment on the pick in
all caps simply writing mom to which
gwyneth replied
with three crime laughing emojis the
mother-daughter duo have been spending a
lot of time together recently
relaxing in the sun getting their sweat
on
and even teaming up with gwyneth's mom
and apple's grandma blythe danner
for a goop video i'm in my garden
and i'm here to tell you about some very
special
goop products today that we have coming
out with some
very special guests to help me tell you
all
about them listen closely that's apple
off camera asking the questions
what advice would you give your younger
self grow up
get your [__] together man as for
gwyneth
well she insists she's just like us
here's what she told et in 2018
about striving to do her best you have
good days you have bad days we have days
where
our we're incredibly critical of
ourselves and we have days when we're in
like more of a zen
space there are days we think we're
terrible mother
we missed a game or we ate way too much
cheesecake and we beat ourselves up and
i think really what we
try to do at goop is just say hey we're
all here we're all human beings
we're trying we're just making an effort
to feel good if we can
ask good questions optimize our lives
without being
too hard on ourselves
you